hi i'm eric voss and the mandalorian on
disney plus is an
excellent star wars series with a
misleading title the series was first
pitched as the story of a solo
gunslinger but when the first episode
premiered
we all learned very quickly that it was
so so much more
thanks to little green baby jesus now i
get why the creative team wanted to
hide this reveal it was pretty amazing
but really this series deserves to be
titled something like
baby yoda and the mandalorian because
it's not about the mandalorian by
himself it's about his
relationship with this little nugget
without the child i don't think we'd be
that interested in the show
but why is the connection between these
two characters so endearing to us
despite one being a puppet and the other
being a faceless best scar helmet
i'm gonna break down the unique nature
of the relationship between mando and
baby yoda
with some interesting visuals and
choices that the people who made these
episodes
snuck in there to make us root for these
two so hard
and freak out anytime they're separated
okay so when mando and baby yoda first
meet
their relationship seems to take
inspiration from the manga and film
series
lone wolf and cub a weary traveling
warrior forced to escort an adorable
moppet
who ends up teaching him a thing or two
we've seen versions of this duo and
other media
and yeah we've seen it a bit in star
wars stories but what makes mando and
baby yoda different is the kind of
accidental way they come together like
there's no assignment from higher
authorities or destiny
mando is a violent killer who took on a
gig to find a bounty and was totally
prepared to kill it but at the last
second he
softens and the whole mystery of the
series from then on is why
why does mando love this kid and why
again and again does he sacrifice
the little he has why does he throw
himself in harm's way
ought to protect this stranger a
stranger whom he has no idea the
significance of since he doesn't know
anything about yoda or the jedi order
now we should say this doesn't seem like
too huge a mystery to us as we're
watching it
like as viewers if we found an adorable
kid we would
probably feel some sense of paternal and
tribalistic duty to keep it safe but in
the context of the show it's worth
remembering that the universe of star
wars is
horribly cruel to children nearly every
kid we meet in this universe has a real
shitty life
young anakin skywalker and those kids on
canto bight in the last jedi are
slaves young jen erso young rey young
mando they're
refugees from war the young lanes of the
jedi temple i guess had it okay for a
bit but really only because the jedi
sought out force sensitive kids across
the galaxy and highly
pressured their parents to give away
these kids to their cult
so they would never see their parents
again and then at the end of it all the
kids got
wrecked during order 66 so how good was
the jedi order for them
so really mando has no practical reason
to care for baby yoda
the kid brings nothing but trouble into
his life and indeed mando very nearly
gives baby yoda away to a client who
intends to kill it but then halfway
through episode 3
mando makes a big choice he goes back
into burner her socks compound
on navarro and john wicks his way
through stormtroopers to bust this kid
free and escape with him
it is a fully impractical insane
decision one that violates
everything about his bounty hunter code
and it only makes sense
as the decision made for love so again
why does mando love baby yoda why do any
of us love anything
what is love baby odor don't have meat
on him well for my
limited experience i feel confident in
telling you that
love is best described as the feeling of
home see human beings evolved as tribal
creatures we cling closely to warm
campfires and familiar kin
and then as we wander away into our
lives away from the campfire we are
always in search of a new campfire
a new tribe and we only feel love when
we feel at home
again and don't get too impressed or
sentimental i'm just romanticizing
rick's depressing tape listen morty i
hate to break it to you but what people
call love
is just a chemical reaction that compels
animals to breed it hits hard morty then
it slowly fades
leaving you stranded in a failing
marriage i did it your parents are gonna
do it
break the cycle morty rise above focus
on science happy valentines
but both rick sanchez and mando are lone
wolves who
out of love cling to their tribes and
this
need for tribe is at the core of the
mandalorian
mando lost his family as a young boy but
he was saved by a group of mandalorians
and they
in a sense became his adopted tribe he
offers whatever earnings he makes back
to his tribe as a kind of tribute but he
still doesn't quite fit in
he comes into conflicts with other
members of the tribe and his armorer
reminds him that he has not yet selected
a signet
a signet representing the inner clans of
the mandalorian people
well that all changes when he meets baby
yoda baby yoda reminds mando of his
own beginnings the visuals reinforce the
parallel nature of their origins
remember mando began as a kid hiding
behind shutter doors
from a killer droid before getting saved
by a stranger in a mandalorian helmet
baby yoda
also hides behind shutter doors and is
saved at the last minute
when mando shoots ig-11 mando as a boy
got flown away from conflict
peering over the shoulder of his
mandalorian savior baby yoda is depicted
in the same angle in the final episode
and the way baby yoda's face reflects
from mando's chrome helmet
mando sees his reflection in the child
they are both orphans from war
both survivors thanks to the mercy of a
warrior so mando realizes that baby oda
might be the only person who could ever
truly understand him
season one shows us mando's transition
from the tribe he was adopted into
to the tribe he chooses for himself
early episodes established him as an
outer tier general member of the
mandalorian tribe but by the end of the
season he has transitioned
into his new tribe which the armorer
calls the clan
of two and the final minutes make this
new tribe official
with the item that mando gives baby yoda
the mythosar skull
the ancient crest of the mandalorian
people it once hung kind of like a
banner in
mando's former home the tunnels of
navarro now it's with his new home
the family that he loves so whenever we
hold our breath in terror when baby oda
gets put in danger and then
exhale a sigh of relief when he's back
in amanda's arms it's not just because
the kid is an adorable huge
precious pee it's because we know how
much mando needs him
and i don't care how intense the
affection is between joker and harley
quinn or falcon winter soldier rick and
morty scarlet witch and vision
no one needs each other as much as those
two do
[Music]
you